we could reduce the size of defense
spending we could reduce the amount of
social welfare spending so that you know
most transfer payments you know where
tax dollars go to a favored group those
aren't going to poor people they're not
going to people who need food clothing
and shelter they're around to middle
class people you know to subsidize
student loans to subsidize Health Care
to subsidize mortgage interest payments
like we need to radically reduce the
size scope and spending of government
and have it be effective and efficient
on the people it's helping and that is
the beginning that would be a reboot
that I think would help us become a
livelier more responsive Society